[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum thank you again for
joining this week uh if you're here for
cat mcnamara i think it's a really great
interview and you're gonna have a lot of
fun and if you like the interview i ask
you to stick around and subscribe and
help this little podcast out write a
review subscribe the um the handles on
instagram and twitter ryan uh twitter is
that inside of you pod and uh instagram
facebook is
that's podcast very simple what happened
so uh
check us out write a review and uh
support the podcast so it keeps going
and we'd like to keep going we like the
podcast and a lot of folks are digging
it so hopefully you'll like this uh this
interview a few things i want to just
pump up the animal rescue mission
i am on the board uh the animal rescue
mission rescues rehabs and finds forever
homes for abused and neglected animals
uh if you want to donate just go to the
animalrescuemission.org
the
animalrescuemission.org also if you want
to uh donate to the ronald mcdonald
house i love them
they're an amazing
amazing organization go to also go to
echoesofhope.org if you want to support
foster youth
and food on foot
i'm a board member on all these things
for the most part
foodonfoot.org and help the homeless
crisis
in los angeles or around the world i
wish there were more food on foots
i want to thank everybody for listening
again and uh if you want any cool merch
go to the inside of you online store
we've got great stuff smallville stuff
lunch boxes and blah blah blah just take
a look at it go to the inside you online
store if you want to make any bookings
or zoom bookings go to sunspin.com
that's the band's website that's my new
band not my new but i keep saying my new
band it's my
it's our second album it's coming out in
september so hopefully you'll like it
keep looking forward it's coming out
soon and uh support that um
what else can i say
i mean i'm the cons are done for a while
i don't have any cons until november
december going to columbus and
uh pittsburgh and san francisco so if
we're out of cons must be only pros then
only pros no more cons in this man's
world you know the uh the i feel like
the anxiety today is is better
it's a little bit better so maybe um
you know i'm talking to my guy tomorrow
and uh i'm just hoping this i just
rebound from this it's a struggle man
anxiety is a struggle boy and this is
probably the worst anxiety i've had in a
while so anybody out there suffering
from anxiety that you you know get help
and uh it will get better i'm getting
better and uh it was it was tough man
exercise go for walks i know you don't
want to do it i know your body doesn't
want to do it you're tired you just want
to lie down that's depression you know
that's that's what i i deal with and uh
so i'm just rooting for you guys
as i know hopefully you're rooting for
me great guest today kat mcnamara uh
what can i say about her this is her
second time or third time on
uh
she's got the new show walker
independence
she's got arrow to talk about she's got
a lot to talk about i love her
instagrams her posts
they're full of life she's a fascinating
young lady i sound like i'm an old man
and she's a fascinating young lady it's
just fascinating ryan i i admire her
tenacity i admire her
oh man sorry it's been a
long morning and uh we love you but
without further ado stick around for the
top tier oh of course join patreon to
support the podcast i forgot to mention
that i'll message you after you join
it's patreon.com inside of you without
further ado let's get inside of
catherine mcnamara
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience i'll have to get the walker
family in one day and just do a combo
episode you just jumped right in with
the walker family
i love this i mean i just interviewed
jared padalecki
i saw we were talking about you did you
listen
i i heard bits and pieces i mean i think
twitter was just a flutter yeah at any
mention of of this new show anytime you
get those supernatural walker boys on
it's true i guess it wouldn't be walker
boys it would be walker boy
the walk well the walker the walker yeah
the walker
is walker that successful i mean it's
got to be successful if they're doing a
prequel to it
i think it's there's so much to it i
mean it is you know it's that there's a
familiar audience and it's it's that
nostalgia that westerns bring out in
people i think you know there's such a
familiarity to it but
it with the sort of resurgence of
westerns right now it provides such a
great opportunity to take a genre that
everyone thinks they know and make it
new and make it fresh and i think you
know the the new walker's been able to
do that in a really cool way with what
jared's done with his show and now
taking it back to the 1870s we're able
to do that all over again um and sort of
be in the universe that very much our
own
our own entity did you
were you watching
a lot of walker did you have to watch a
lot of walkers to sort of get ready for
this i mean did you even audition for
this prequel so guys if you're listening
she's obviously doing this prequel to
the show walker that jared padalecki is
on and she's doing the prequel which
takes place in the 1800s now i'm
thinking this is the season season three
of walker i think so yeah so it's that
successful where all of a sudden they're
like let's do a prequel i mean small was
super successful why did they do a
prequel i guess we were the prequel
because it was small what was before
they became superman but that's that
shows a lot of uh
a lot of love for the show
oh absolutely and what's what's what i
get a kick out of is you know as far as
the cw goes the last time i spoke to you
i was playing stephen amell's daughter
20 years in the future and now in some
other alternate universe i'm playing
jared padilecki's great great great
great grandmother
and
i just i think it's wonderful there's
some multiverse where you know that
exists and if someone can explain to me
that
history i'll take it did you watch
every episode of walker to prepare
have you seen all the seasons every
episode like just not that it matters
because you're before you don't really
have to pay attention to anything if it
was me i was like this doesn't relate to
me i'm i'm before this well no similarly
to you know when i
when i jumped onto arrow i watched all
six at that point six seasons that were
in existence to sort of see what stephen
and what emily had done to create that
relationship with those characters to be
you know the spawn thereof right of
felicity as it were um but for this i i
wanted to get a feel for the world and
for what the walker family represented
and so i did i watched a good deal of it
and also you know being a massive
supernatural fan and i'm keegan allen's
one of my oldest friends in las vegas
he was on the podcast he was such a good
dude he's such a great
it it scares me when i meet people that
are so kind and i'm like are they really
like that is he really that good of a
dude
yeah because i interviewed him i'm like
i love you
and and then i'm like he can't be that
sweet there's got to be some catch
yeah but just in talking to no and i had
a conversation with you know a couple
folks very early on and the biggest
thing that spoke to me about you know
the walker family and the walker
franchise is that there's so much love
in it and there's so much kindness in it
and just good people that want to make
good television and tell good stories
and that to me is why i'm here in the
first place and so you know to to be a
part of something that has such good
will surrounding it it's a real gift
because as you know we spend the
majority of our lives you know 17-hour
days slogging through whatever it is
doing what we love yeah but if you don't
love the people you work with it it's an
extra bit of effort and it just it makes
it makes those days on set and all the
hard work that every single person on
set pours into it mean that much more
when you love the people too do you
notice when actors always say you know
the hours that they work it always gets
longer and longer it's like we work 12
hours a day we work 14 we're working 24
hours a day
we worked so hard
but the hours are long especially in the
beginning when you're shooting a series
i mean what are your hours on the
prequel and how many episodes have you
done so far
we've only done one so far we haven't
gone back we just got our series pickup
and we're at upfronts and did the whole
thing um which was very exciting but our
hours because most of our
being you know a show that shoots
outside being in 1870s western most of
our days are daylight dependent
so it's a lot of and for you know for
folks who aren't in this industry um you
know that means when the sun goes down
we're done for the day is that true we
don't do anything more there's very few
night shifts
we had we had one or two days i mean
that's a huge testament to to larry tang
who was our director of this pilot who
uh laid out we had eight days to shoot
this thing and he did the whole thing in
uh eight or nine days i forget because
it all blurs together but he laid out
this massive undertaking and made it a
dream of a process by just the way that
he was able to put the days together and
the way that they were able to shoot
things between our first ad our director
of photography and him
it was it was honestly such a dream i'm
so so happy that we're keeping this
family together and taking it to
savories and this is the is this the
second time on a series you've had a
lead role
yeah it is this is uh shadowhunters was
the first time i was sort of thrust into
this position at 19 years old not doing
what i'm doing but
that that show
taught me how to make television because
i was surrounded by
such an incredible cast and such an
incredible crew of people that
you know were kind and amazing artists
but also willing to
show me the ropes as someone who wanted
to learn
um and now
you know having those examples and and
getting to watch steven for a couple
years and getting to sort of work on a
few other sets
going into another show
as i mean
i play make-believe for a living am i
really an adult i don't know but as as
an adult on paper yeah you know yeah uh
it's it's nice to be able to try and
bring some of that
um synergy and that that family
idea to to a new show i mean you're the
lead right
i am i am abigail walker i mean so it's
the show is on your shoulders so if it
fails it's your fault
thanks rosie no no no no but honestly is
it does that i guess my point was that i
mean i know you could handle it but you
know we've talked about this in the past
and i want to get into it again but
because you you don't really stress a
lot do you think now that you have a
lead role in this other series and it's
very demanding and you're abigail walker
is that do you feel any of the load do
you feel the stress do you feel the any
anxiety are you getting are you doing
all right
i i'm not feeling all right i would i
would say i always think of it as a
responsibility at more than a stressor
or a pressure because you know obviously
there is a lot writing you know for a
lack of a better horsepower yeah yeah on
this show and on this character and and
there's a lot of expectation for it but
those are the sort of jobs that i love
because it is a challenge and it is
something that it forces me to rise to
the occasion not that i wouldn't attempt
to anyway
but
it's exciting to to be a part of a story
that people want to see and that people
are anticipating and they're excited to
be a part of and excited to tell the
story and you know between
abigail walker is one thing and she's a
fantastic character and i'm i'm so
grateful and so lucky to get to play her
but she's not the only fantastic
character in this story you know that's
something that that drew me to the
script in the first place is that every
single character you you look at them on
the surface and you meet them for the
first time and you think you know who
they are and you think you know what
you're going to get out of them and then
suddenly
they present something entirely
different that you know it takes all of
these tropes that we know and love of
westerns and reinvents them and
re-examines them and goes well this is
what we know but is that how the west
actually was and maybe there's more to
the story
is it complicated is it challenging on
set to do i mean what are they asking
you to do what things can you tell me
that you've done like
you're obviously riding horses
yes i'm riding horses there's horses
there's shotguns there's
a 20-pound dress
there's a corset there's you know and
and you know the heavy emotional trauma
of having your you know as we see from
the trailer having your husband murdered
in the first you know x amount of
minutes of the pilot that's what happens
yeah that's well you see that you know
as as we start as you get to see the
trailer you uh
abigail walker has set off with her
husband into what she's assuming is
going to be a fresh start and a new life
out west
um she's from boston and she and her
husband have decided to take this
journey he's you know meant to be
the sheriff and she is gonna help him
start this new life
um
but her you know her entire within the
first x number of minutes of the show
her entire life her entire world is torn
apart
and
she is forced to
start anew and and for a woman in the
1870s to be on her own
and have nothing and no one and be a
complete stranger in not only a new town
but a new world of the west
it's it's daunting but it takes a
character like abia walker who has the
education and the strength and the
tenacity and the willingness to go
you know what no i'm not gonna let this
defeat me i'm gonna embrace this and she
takes on this agency that you don't see
a lot in women of that time
and she's also surrounded by
a cast of characters men and women alike
who recognize that agency and who give
her the opportunity to
exhibit that and to exert that in this
new world and it's such an exciting
story to tell because it is so
uncommon for a western there is no
shrinking violet there is no damsel in
distress there is no
cowboy who cannot be beaten
there is no
character that is truly good there is no
character that is truly bad there is all
shades of grey and that's the most
exciting thing is that no one comes out
of the west unscathed is there some dark
[ __ ] there's some really dark stuff
we don't shy away from it i mean and
that's what you get when you get you
know a writer like
sheamus and you get a director like
larry and you get this world where
i mean we saw it with the pilot of
walker you know you saw what jared's
character went through and the pilot of
that show within the first 15 minutes
it's
they don't shy away from putting these
characters through when you saw what
happened to matt barr's character at the
end of his season of walker there's a
reason that he's now on our show and not
still on that one you know his
characters go through things people die
things change the world is shattered
right you know wagons go up in flames
and
you're left with the ashes and having to
rebuild
inside you is brought to you by conair
uh you know what i hate going to the dry
cleaners i'm flying a lot ryan i go all
over the place and my clothes are always
wrinkled
but not anymore ryan
no not anymore
uh
the conair turbo extreme steam steam and
iron two in one it's the most powerful
handheld steamer it's so easy to use and
so small you could pack it in your bag
and travel with it and you never have to
worry about wrinkly dinkley clothes not
anymore fast and easy wrinkle removal
extra large sole plate can be used
vertical or horizontal also works
without steam as a dry iron advanced
heat technology is ready almost
instantly and obliterates wrinkles with
turbocharged dry steam
four settings for delicate to turbo is
perfect for all fabrics
kills 99.9 percent of all bacteria
sanitizes around the house and refreshes
clothing easy to use great for at home
or on the go to get yours today go to
amazon and search conair turbo extreme
steam and look for the steam and iron
two in one
inside of you is brought to you by
shopify what would i do without shopify
you know i've been using shopify since
the beginning of this podcast folks to
sell merch and boy do they make it easy
i don't i can't imagine anyone else
doing what they do uh i can check out
what sells really well what's not
selling uh up to date monthly income
uh the list goes on it's so easy to use
i can use this thing uh i think when i
first started i think shopify i had a
t-shirt and now i have like 30 or 40
items and it's so easy to manage
thank you shopify uh shopify gives
entrepreneurs the resources once
reserved for big business so upstarts
startups and established businesses
alike can sell everywhere synchronize
online and in-person sales and
effortlessly stay informed scaling your
business is a journey of endless
possibility litemine shopify powers
millions of businesses from first sale
to full scale reach customers online and
across social networks with an
ever-growing suite of channel
integrations and apps including facebook
instagram ticktalk pinterest and more
gain insights as you grow with detailed
reporting of conversion rates profit
margins and beyond
more than a store shopify grows with you
this is possibility powered by shopify
shopify is more than a store connect
with your customers drive sales manage
your day to day shopify instantly lets
you accept all major payment methods
go to shopify.com
inside all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features
grow your business with shopify today go
to shopify.com
inside right now
shopify.com slash
inside
god it's gotta be so cool my friend troy
rudolph he's he lives in um
where does he live now who gives a [ __ ]
uh
he lives in oregon uh portland yeah he
lives in portland but he's uh god i'm so
jealous i want to be in a western had
you ever been in a western or anything
like this before
no was it just totally like did you have
your mannerisms are they are they sort
of too modern and sometimes they say oh
you're very today we have to you have to
it's you have to learn how to be from
that time period right yeah i mean it's
interesting for me i grew up doing
ballet i grew up you know doing theater
so i'm very used to kind of
figuring out different eras as it were
and you know everyone calls me grandma
anyway i admit i bake and i drink scotch
i'm basically an 85 year old in a 26
year old body it's just sort of who i am
um
but
it it did take a bit of adjusting
because again as you know most of my
characters in the last few years have
been you know leather jackets jeans
kicking ass
yeah you know swords and arrows and
kicking butt
not you know corset and a bustle and a
giant skirt and
being a bostonian educated lady yeah how
long does it take you to get dressed in
these dresses how long does it take to
put one of these things on
it doesn't take long i i have to give a
huge shout out to the wardrobe team on
our pilot they
built and found and sourced all of these
amazing different pieces my dress was
built from from head to toe the first
fitting i had it was a bolt of fabric
and a corset and then by the time we got
to set it was all of these layers but um
it's the first time i've actually had to
have help getting dressed in the morning
on set
and it's a very different it's a
different world but i
i sort of love it you know they gave me
the option to not wear the corset and to
just kind of cheat here and there you
will eventually yeah eventually you'll
say no corset everyone says that but i
gotta say it's
it's a different posture and it forces
you to stand differently and move
differently and hold yourself
differently
i'm a big fan of that you know it's the
same with with arrow when you put on the
super suit and you zip up that you put
on the hood and the mask or with
shadowhunters when we put on all the
tattoos every day or you know when i
took the stand and i dyed my hair pink
there's a there's a difference and
there's kind of a mask that you put on
and you sort of go oh no
that's the separation of of me and abby
and me and this person and that person
and it it just puts you in it more who
are you really enjoying working with or
who who are most of your scenes with
in this prequel
ah i i was lucky because getting to be
sort of the audience's eyes coming into
the town of independence texas and and
sort of entering this world there's a
one of my favorite parts of the pilot is
there's a series of scenes where abigail
meets every character for the first time
and you sort of get to see little
glimmers of what these relationships
could be and how
diverse and
vast this town is and how many different
kinds of people have all settled here
and that's that's i think the most
beautiful thing that's sort of
perhaps the biggest allegory for our
world today that has to do with this
story is that
the west is all about
people coming together and either
fighting each other or working together
to survive right and there's a very
clear choice and it's very clear in the
west because it's a very distinct
archaic world in a lot of ways but
each person that comes to independence
texas has to choose am i going to be a
part of this community am i going to
cooperate am i going to make friends or
am i going to make enemies and how how
will that best serve me moving forward
you worked with mark shepard right i did
how was that what a treat what a treat
diddy did he have the english accent or
did he put a southern accent on
uh he gets a little bit texan in our
show
do you get a little texan do you uh do
you have a little draw
this is the hardest thing for me perhaps
about this show because i i was born in
the south and so when i first learned to
talk i had a southern accent i'm not
allowed to use it for this show why is
that because i'm from boston i'm from
boston in the 1870s and so even even the
boston accent as we know it today didn't
quite exist yet
so pacquiao don't have it yet
yeah exactly i can't even you know have
that kind of fun and then everyone else
around me is getting all texas and i
can't i can't participate in that either
so it's it's a it's a very it's a good
exercise for me and i appreciate it by
the way you you say that you know
i mean look you picture i picture you as
not someone who's really edgy the most
edgy person but as you get older as i've
talked to you over the years now i'm
seeing tattoos on you did you always
have those tattoos
not always i don't remember if i had
these last time what do they say what
are they
this one this one's my probably my
favorite one it says not fragile oh
it's um my my boxing coach uh he was one
of our stunt coordinators on
shadowhunters he's the man who taught me
how to fight
um he used to always tell me that um and
it it was a phrase that i found out
later on meant a lot more to him than i
ever realized um and he's since passed
and
[Music]
yeah he's gone far too soon and he was a
very very good man um
and taught me everything i know and
loved him dearly but
it's just a little reminder
of
him and just as a kind of a thank you to
everything that
he gave me that's beautiful i like that
what's the other tattoo
oh goodness um that's how i drink
whiskey is that what it says
no no
i mean it should just because
um
so many um this one is a it's a replica
of a necklace that my grandfather gave
me when i was 16. it's the attitude
meter of an airplane because he he built
an airplane in his retirement and got
his pilot's license and did all this and
when i was 16 he wrote me this beautiful
card um instead you know as long as you
keep your wings straight you'll be fine
and i just moved away from home and
it's just they're all all of my tattoos
are just little reminders of the people
that i love and
things in my life that i that are very
important to me
um i always make myself wait a year
before i get any
any new tattoo because then at least i
know if i still want it after a year
that's smart it's very smart it could be
okay yeah
it's hard though it's hard
who was the uh who told you when walker
was picked up the prequel was picked up
who called you
i actually was on a plane
when it happened and so i didn't get a
phone call i was flying home from
a uh a comic-con in
um birmingham actually
and i landed
and my phone exploded and i was getting
all of these text messages of where are
you what's going on why we heard from
you from everybody from that only from
the cast from my team everybody's like
what's wrong because they know they know
if we'd all been anticipating this news
and we were all waiting and kind of see
we didn't know when and if we would know
and i had my phone was just i had to
play catch up and i didn't even know
what the news was
what was it that
was where it it
you knew that hey i got this
was it a text message that you knew
you're like oh this is it
we have a chat with larry um we have a
little a little group text of like the
guest and and larry our director because
he's been he's been dad to all of us
kids throughout this whole process and
he's one of the most transparent
directors i've ever worked with and i've
never been more grateful um but he you
know when i saw that there were 75
messages and most of them with
positive uh
messages as opposed to you know crying
emojis right um there's bottles of
champagne as opposed to tears i i sort
of put the pieces together that's
amazing and do they just pick it up for
one season at a time it's just like hey
you're picked up for the
full season
yeah well we didn't know um
i don't even know if we have official
official word as to how many episodes
we're doing and sort of all of that but
we found out that you know we got the we
got season one and we're going to up
fronts and which we just came back from
and that was
that was a really cool experience to
sort of get to be there with you know
the cw family and and see all the execs
that i've known from arrow and as i'm
sure you know all of those folks
incredibly well
um and see jared and jensen and have you
know us and there's the workers and the
winchesters and all of us kind of
getting to do our new thing and
be the next generation it's it's really
beautiful that's amazing i mean how with
all you're so busy you're always since i
started talking to you it's like god how
does this girl do it
how does this woman do it
but i'm like how do you
how do you date how do you have time for
personal relationships or anything like
that do you have time to date do you
have time to have i mean are you dating
someone are you
talking to someone are you interested in
someone
you find time you find time to have
those you know to to have a personal
life and to you know when when the
person
you find it's it's funny i've something
that i've learned in the last several
years especially with shadowhunters and
arrow and this and everything else and
comic cons and you know the life we live
yeah
you find those moments of
personal life that are just simple
that are
mean so much yeah and you know when the
when the people mean a lot to you like
family like someone you're dating it
it's
it's easy to find those pockets of time
because you just do it
really it just seems like it'd be so
hard like you're always out
somewhere else in another state and
another country you're in london right
now right
yeah what are you doing in london i
sleep well on international flights you
know that
i uh i i do really well i know i'm i'm
lucky because i'm tiny and i can curl up
into a into a corner and you know sleep
even in the in the worst of coach
flights
wait wait wait wait you're not taking
coach anymore
oh yeah you still coach it up
oh yeah how often
oh most of the time not on the studio's
dime
well not on the stage i mean look you
know there's there's union rules that
but you know there's
they take very good care of us when it's
for work which is lovely and i'm so
grateful for that but
i don't know i was never used to
anything like that before so
you know might as well just i'm
perfectly fine curling up in coach do
you do you get noticed a lot
people come up to you
yeah it's it always surprises me and i
um
it happens more when i have red hair
than when i have blonde hair i like the
blonde hair
thank you i do i dig it i'm digging it
thank you look a little bit of arrow
leftovers
um
but no i'll be i'll be back red soon
because abby's a ginger and you know we
lean full tilt into that which i think
there might be some fun irish bostonian
things we might be having the
opportunity to explore
down the line
inside of you is brought to you by helix
sleep uh if if you guys aren't uh
if you're tired
all day
if you're struggling
a lot of times it has to do with sleep
and if you're not getting the right
sleep a good sleep at night your day is
most likely going to be well
screwed
uh helix makes unbelievable mattresses
and so you can sleep all night and they
have this great quiz that you take and
believe me it only takes 10 seconds i
mean it's quick
uh and it just helps them figure out
what mattress is right for you
i don't know if any other
company does this it's pretty
fascinating
the quiz takes two minutes at most to
complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress that you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers i took the helix quiz
i am a medium
uh mattress sleeper um i don't like it
too soft i don't like it too hard right
there in the middle like the porridge
who did the porridge thing goldilocks
that's exactly right it's been awesome
getting messages from all my listeners
about how much helix has really helped
them
so thank you helix and thank you
listeners
if you're looking for a mattress just
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it it was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 and by gq and
wired magazine ryan where can they go
just go to helixsleep.com
inside take their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk free and they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
inside that's helix sleep dot com slash
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
now a word from our sponsor better help
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
that's how our brains work so why don't
we treat them that way
how we care for our minds affects how we
experience life so it's important to
invest time and care into keeping them
healthy there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain learning a new
language or taking power naps there's
also better help online therapy better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat only therapy
sessions so you don't have to see anyone
on camera if you don't want to you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside
all right so you don't mind flying coach
you could easily do it
yeah
really you don't splurge and say you
know it's on my time i'm gonna go first
class so you kind of you're a little
cheap be honest sometimes i do i mean
look you know there's i the frequent
flyer miles are a beautiful thing when
you can upgrade you upgrade and that's
great but
i'm i don't know i'm not i'm generally
not a very you're down to earth is what
you are you're down to earth
from missouri girl i'm a country girl at
heart you know can take a girl out of
the midwest but she's always gonna end
up back in the western that's true that
is very true
uh do you miss me a smoke
i do 100
and
i do and it's one of those things that i
got it i got the opportunity to go back
and and pick her up again on the flash
last year they did this big armageddon
event where they brought in a bunch of
fun characters as the world was ending
as it always is somewhere in the cw
verse
and it was actually quite emotional um
because you know green arrow was one of
the last jobs i did before the pandemic
um barring the stand and a few other
things
and getting to go back to the you know
vancouver film studios and put on the
suit again and it was such kind of a
bookmark of it felt like home and it was
the first time that in two and a half
years of
abnormal and weird and unknown
environment that we'd all been living in
i just felt normal again i felt like i
was home can you just jump into that
character again mia can you just jump
right into it without thinking can you
go from abigail walker to mia
probably and i think it's just because i
know there's characters that you just
know when you live in their skin for
years
they're just a part of you and and
that's that's what i find exciting
that's why i love doing television so i
keep coming back to it what'd you do so
you don't mind guest starring you'll
always go back to be a guest star you'll
do whatever if you like it
oh yeah just put that green arrow signal
in the sky and i'll come running
really
oh yeah do you think you'll go back to
it do you think they'll bring you back
as mia i would hope so i mean i'm not
dead
you know i'm not dead on a slab yet so
i'm hoping
and plus my brother's still missing it's
a whole thing like that
i gotta i gotta find the other felicity
baby you know what i mean there's like
there's you know can't have wanton queen
children running around the euroverse
do you get paid for doing if you do like
batwoman flash and supergirl all in one
episode like crossing over do you get
paid your salary and each
for each show
i don't remember there's some
i'm interested in knowing that yeah
where it yeah there's there's some way
that they
accounted for it in the contract where
it was like fair to everyone which
i'm fine with you know as i'm i mean i'm
you know me i'm an economist i'm a
businesswoman at heart but as long as
it's fair
i'll you know i'll take it you'll take
it
what about uh you know the spin-off i
think we talked about it maybe did we
talk about it before
probably briefly because they were it
was briefly you know they were it was
called green arrow and the in the
cranberries no in the canaries
and the canaries and it was a spin-off
of arrow and it didn't go now this seems
odd to me because it seems like
everything you touch goes
works all right now everything but how
do you deal with rejection how do you
deal with that were you just kind of
like or was that a kind of was that a
sting did it hurt
that was hard you know again because
it's mia and it's a character that i
love so much and you know we all worked
so hard on that pilot and it's
that was such a
you know it's such a journey we all say
that but it was in between
crisis on infinite earths and the series
finale of arrow we shot a backdoor pilot
for this spin-off and somehow our crew
was so incredible and they pulled it
together and the writers and everyone
was stretched so thin
and made a pilot that was
great and people really seemed to love
it and we loved it and
it was very well received but it's just
one of those things that
you have to trust in the universe that
if it's meant to be yours it will be and
if it's not there's something else out
there for you and
i feel i mean as much as i would have
loved to do that show and and i still
would love to continue mia's journey
moving forward the fact that i that mia
still exists in the world
and i have a new story to tell with a
new character that is equally as
challenging and interesting and and
complex
it's really exciting yeah i can't
complain no did they let you see the
pilot
i've seen bits of it so
really so aren't you curious that you
want to see the whole thing
i do want to see it
watching myself isn't my favorite thing
really wait a minute
i didn't know that
yeah you don't like watching yourself
i don't i don't love it i like it for
the learning experience of it you know i
i i can enjoy it for the story but i
i always want to i always think there's
room to
to improve and to learn from things
you've done and there's ways that you
can keep pushing yourself to be better
and you know being the perpetual student
that i am i tend to see those things
more than other things at times
um but that's just part of it and i've
made my piece with it you know i've been
doing this for years now i've made my
piece of the fact that yeah that's not
the most comfortable thing for me but i
would rather
be a little bit uncomfortable and get to
enjoy everyone's work and what we put so
hard in and in celebrating that together
then avoid it entirely just because of
something in my head do you watch the
episodes of um green arrow that you were
in and all the bat women the crossovers
do you watch every episode that you're
in
i do because i try and live tweet it's
something i love we started doing that
with shadowhunters and i just i fell so
in love with that process because it's
maybe it's the theater actor in me i
don't know but getting to see the live
reaction of folks on twitter as things
happen and things that we've kept so
secret and hidden and worked so hard to
curate so specifically as they hit the
screen then the internet kind of blows
up in its own little way and and people
are excited or they're happy or they're
upset or they're sad or they're scared
or whatever it is
it's just nice to be able to share that
and then to drop little behind the
scenes things and have those
conversations live with with the viewers
it's fantastic yeah i wanna know though
what you look at what you see when you
watch yourself
what is it that you what is it that like
you know i'll watch myself and i go
dude gosh your head's enormous
god what is that is that a zit are you
too old for a zit how do you have a zit
on your chin
oh my god why'd you
i'm hard on myself too
but do you do that or can you can you
honestly sit back because sometimes i'll
go no you look pretty good right that's
good lighting that must be really good
lighting congrats on the lighting team
but do you look at yourself and it's
hard to watch you because you you know
your choices or you don't like how you
look or how hard are you on yourself and
what is it you're hard on
doesn't sound right it depends it really
depends and it you know that's one of
those things that it's it's depends on
the scene or the day or the choice or
the lighting or whatever it is and
you know i i think a lot of it is
thinking back through what my process
was
and going wait i was trying to figure
out what take it is i think it's the
nerd in me i'm trying to be like was
that that tiger was that that take and
did i make this choice or where was my
head when i was doing that or it was
just why did you why do you make that
face when you feel that thing i don't
know sure
go for it maybe not the best choice but
you know baby don't make that choice
next time wait a minute wait a minute do
you make faces and go uh
what if it's a face that you really a
reaction that was real and most people
see it as a real reaction but you don't
like the look of how you reacted
well if it's real then i can't argue
with it we can't argue with it then
that's that's what i that i'm doing my
job you know
um
honestly i've made a fool of myself
enough on camera over the course of my
life i'm i'm not bothered by looking
silly did you watch you watched walker
pilot right you watched that
i've seen bits and pieces of it bits and
pieces i would demand i am the lead of
this show
i will watch it when i want to i am the
leader and by the way
do you is it is it a lot of you know
because you did it on um shadowhunters
but to be the leader i mean
is there something that you go into
every day no matter if you're feeling
down or you're feeling whatever that you
go into positive is there something you
think about like hey i'm the leader here
i have a responsibility i've got to
change my attitude or i've got to think
about things differently
i think that's part of it you know if
there's anything i've learned from from
watching other people in this position
and from being the position myself it's
you have a responsibility not only to
you know play the character but also to
be the example on set
and and be the example of
how you want the set to run and what
what environment do you want to work in
and what environment do you want the
people around you that you care about to
be working in and do you want that to be
a positive collaborative environment or
do you want that to be a different kind
of environment and it's your choice
every day and now granted as an actor i
control nothing
and i can do nothing except
put forth my best efforts to be
a team player and to be a cog in the
machine and make everyone's job easier
in any way that i can because you know
as actors
our jobs are made about as easy as they
possibly can be
um given that you know we we have a
chair to sit in and we have someone who
lays out our clothes and helps us put on
our corset in the morning and make sure
we don't have stuff in our face unless
we're supposed to you know and and make
sure we're lit well
and the cameras and the you know we
we're given a piece of tape to stand on
and someone's there to make sure we're
fed and know where the bathroom is and
all of that stuff i want one of those
every day
right of my life i want somebody to
dress me i want somebody to say hey you
know fix me up i want somebody to tell
me what to do
maybe that's a wife
maybe maybe i don't know it would
certainly make life so much easier yeah
um but but there's something to that
where being in that position
you have new people coming in every day
who whether they're new actors or a day
player in some other department
and everyone's there and you interact
with most people on set every day so if
you can
make someone's day a little bit easier
or put a smile on their face or you know
do or say something silly that makes
them laugh
why not
where do you film
walker
we shot the pilot in uh new mexico
is that where it's gonna film now or
i think so i mean again i'm an actor do
you like new mexico do you want to film
there is that i mean it's kind of away
from everybody
it is but
i sort of like being on location when it
comes to
diving into a series because you really
get to build the family
um and we have a great cast everyone is
so fantastic it's
it's uncanny how well we all just
clicked from day one
and
it's such such a gift especially on a
project like this where you're
working long hours and you're covered in
dust and there's wind and there's
everything all day long you're doing
such emotional stuff where you really
have to dive in head first with you know
on a pilot a group of practical
strangers uh especially in the covet era
when
chemistry rates are done on zoom and you
really don't get to meet until you're in
it and you're working together
um
it's it's such a dream and new mexico is
such a beautiful magical place and
it does have to work for us and that's
that's part of walker and that's part of
walker independence in particular is
that the town is a character
and so we get to really use the
environment around us in every way and
larry really leaned into that as well in
the way that you know he shot it with
yeah we're not going to shy away from
the wind or the dust or the sun or
any kind of harshness of this
environment sounds like hell part of it
that's going to get old though don't you
think that's going to get old it's
really nice and it's go oh it's so real
and then episode 18 you're like good
lord enough with the dust
that's what i would do also
why not have a challenge i guess i mean
how many uh when will it air do you know
i think
fall i know we're on thursdays
that they cw did their big schedule
announcement and we were part of that
um well then you have to start shooting
yeah i think we start pretty soon i'm
not sure exactly when but again this is
all all brand new and it's all branded a
couple of weeks and you don't know how
many episodes yet
i don't know that there's been an
official
stamp on it
so i don't want to speak out of turn
you know i i'm still new i gotta i gotta
gotta stay put i'm not you know i'm not
jared i'm not executive producer
well you will be when they do a prequel
to abigail uh walker uh there you go the
shadow hunters
uh how many episodes did you do that a
year
we did our first season was 13 and then
we did um
20 and 20 and then we did a two-episode
series finale so all in all 55 episodes
you see how though you can remember i
know you can when you did 13 episodes
how much nicer that was and easier and
you had a bigger break and it wasn't as
but when you do 20 episodes you're there
for eight nine months
and it's pretty taxing it's not you know
it's not easy people say being an actor
is so easy and we're just but it's not
it's not like it's not a glamorous job
really
no i mean look i've i've had you're
gonna say about the dust and the wind i
might get
you know you
say that it might become a challenge but
remember i've been covered in
blood and dust you have you know slime
and
all sorts of stuff for the last seven
eight years i'm used to it i love it i
love being in the trenches i love being
my favorite days on set are being head
to toe covered in blood mud sweat and
tears you're a rarity in the trenches
yeah so bring on the dust and the wind
all we are is dust and the remember that
song do you remember that i would hope
so i mean what are you you're 26 now
far more mature than i'll ever be at 26.
no yep you are
uh the new shadowhunters podcast
i'm joining your world
now what do you mean
the podcast world oh the podcast world
yes yes yes who approached you about
this
so i started talking to uh one of our
producers um at this company called
propagate about creating content and
what
else we could do working together just
during the pandemic what else can i do
being a creative someone who wants to be
a multi-hyphenate how can i get involved
and
one of our producers turned to me and
went
you did the show shadowhunters and you
seem to have a really
big fan base for it like there's a
there's a really big fandom that's still
very active i mean oh you have no idea
um and she said well
what if you were to do a podcast maybe
you know re-watching episodes or
interviewing people and
and we started talking and developing it
and and i reached out to dom and said
dom sherwood who played jace my love
interest on the show
i reached out to him and said hey would
you want to
go on this walk down memory lane would
you want to
go back and rewatch and and bring on
some of the rest of the shadow fam and
interview people and discuss this and
and he was totally on board because this
fandom
is
so incredible and i know we've talked
about it at length before but you know
they've they've done so many incredible
things over the years and taken the show
beyond
or taking the fandom beyond us and be on
the show and beyond our characters and
the story and created this beautiful
community
and
you know for me shadowhunters was age 19
to 23. it was such a formative part of
my life and being able to look back on
it now and
relive that and see where all of the
people that were so instrumental in that
process are now and the amazing things
they've done and be able to kind of
continue to celebrate that family it's
really really a wonderful experience
return to the shadows
with dominic sherwood
and catherine mcnamara
indeed wow when is this is it already
going
it is yeah we've started releasing
episodes i think we have about
i want to say
seven or eight episodes out already
really
yeah
and so what do you do do you go back and
watch the episode and then talk about it
so we alternate so dom and i will go
through and the two of us will do a
re-watch of an episode where we
basically break down when the episode
was shot who directed it who wrote it
what the synopsis is and then kind of
talk about it and share as many little
tidbits and stories and all the stuff
we've never been able to talk about
before basically would you go back to uh
would you go back to the shadows would
you go back to shadowhunters if they did
like a tv movie or they wanted to do
another season uh
in a heartbeat really in an absolute
heartbeat yeah you loved it that much
there's not much is there anything that
you don't love or didn't like filming or
didn't like working on without t you
don't have to tell me but has there ever
been something that you're like oh i
wouldn't do that again
um
maybe i mean there's things that have
been more difficult than others but
not because of the story or because of
the character or or you know mostly
because of the people i worked with it's
it's all i've been very lucky in that
the majority of the experiences that
i've had in this industry have been
wonderful and learning experiences and
and things that i would go back to and
people that i would go back to
i mean maybe i'm just a stubborn
optimist
but
yeah
i love what i do
yeah wish i had that out so we'll
yeah and so with the podcast we'll do an
episode of that and then we'll alternate
it with bringing on someone whether it's
a cast member or a director or a
designer or something that that played a
part in the show and usually we try and
pair that with the episodes and so it
kind of gives us a chance to
not only relive the episodes and and
there's some folks that are watching the
show for the first time with our podcast
which is exciting um but then we also
get to to give a little more in depth
and give
other folks a chance to tell their
stories and share their perspective and
it's it's been really fascinating to get
to talk to people that we know so well
and hear stories we've never heard
before when you get busy with walker
though how are you gonna have time to do
that
because i don't need much sleep michael
how many hours of sleep do you sleep how
many hours of sleep do you sleep
uh i i generally on average get about
four to six a night but that's all i've
ever needed how do you have no i know
you're no bags under your eyes unless
this is just perfect lighting but yeah
you're you don't need a lot of sleep you
can go four to six hours and you're
you have a ton of energy for the next 15
hours
yeah that's that's how i function best i
mean i can function on less sleep and
have
but
to be at my best that's that's what i
try and you're learning lines pretty
quickly like you could learn them in a
night if you had to
it's a muscle for me the more i do it
the more um the further into a season i
get
the the faster that process becomes and
i think it becomes a rhythm as you know
i mean you know this i don't have to
tell you but making television becomes a
rhythm and you kind of get into the
machine and you can just become a part
of that process it's really hard in the
beginning it's like okay it's like i
gotta learn this and then you're not
ready and you just have to work at it
and then all of a sudden by episode five
six seven you're like okay now i know
this character now it's coming to me
it's easier yes i agree with you than
that yeah you kind of just fall into it
at a certain point and um
it's it's this is again why i love
television because you play these
characters for so long and you get to
live in their skin and
they take on a physicality and a life
and a space of their own and it's it's
exciting to get to build that and build
those relationships and build that world
and then just sort of
set it free
does kat mcnamara ever cry does she get
emotional
yeah she does
yeah i mean look i've got i'm you know
i'm
i'm a
bleeding heart at best because i
i don't know i
i care very deeply about the people and
the things that i care about and and you
know i'm a very positive person but
i'm not unfeeling right
no i didn't i didn't mean it like that
yeah i just meant like i do cry i cry i
cry
many things i mean i'm not constantly
crying
but half the time the things i cried are
happy things because that's just a big
old softy you're a big old softy
um the new heart a hallmark commercial
you know
speaking of hallmark you did another
hallmark movie right
yeah love classified
and what's so different about this from
other hallmark movies
hallmark took has been taking some big
steps in the last couple of years with
being more open and more
you know implementing more kind of
diverse storylines into
their
their films and their tv shows and
and it's really beautiful to see you
know them
taking steps to to meet the world that
we live in today
um and i was i read this script and i
thought it was in the same way that
shit's creek did the whole you know love
the wine not the label sort of thing
they told a story about love
and letting love surprise you and and
being open to love
in whatever way that comes whether it be
fixing you know some some emotional
damage within your family from the past
or being open to romance for the first
time or being open to dating someone you
never even thought about dating and then
ending up in a beautiful love story
wow well put well put i think you're
maybe describing yourself too
uh maybe maybe hmm are you still tight
with your folks
yeah yeah my my family means a whole lot
to me and i um
i really really really love
just the fact that um
i always talk about this but i i was
raised in a family of
so many women who
never
chose between career and family it was
never you know you you you could be
anything you wanted to be in any
combination of things you wanted to be
if you were willing to to put in the
time and the energy and the work and
having that sort of open possibility
presented to me from a very young age i
think was really beneficial and so i'm
you know i'm forever grateful for that
but surrounded by some really incredible
hard-working folks who's the first
person who texts you or calls you after
maybe an episode of a television show
that you're on or a movie you're doing
uh i usually will hear from
aside from like the cast that i'm
working with
um i usually hear from either my mom or
my grandparents
because they're
so sweet and are they in missouri are
they in missouri yeah do they have that
accent do they have a southern accent
they're like we really love what you
were doing
not quite southern but there there's a
missouri
character yeah
to a voice that i don't really have
because it's midwest midwest field yeah
it's very midwestern but but i'll hear
from them and it's it's so great because
nothing phases any of them but
it's been a lovely thing to see
you know for someone who comes from a
family of science and medical
professionals
for them to get excited about this as a
career
and and as something you know with
longevity and something that is a
profession and um
and they get excited especially about
things like this you know if i'm doing a
western they're so excited right do you
ever seek approval is there someone that
doesn't always give you that little hey
you were really good or you just kind of
want to impress one day you want to get
a message from them or is it are they
you know that are tough to please
i mean i think i'm i'm my own harshest
critic
honestly yeah um i mean there have been
those people in my life but
i don't know something i think life has
taught me in a myriad of ways is that
you have to be okay with who you are and
you have to know that in your own heart
you're doing what's right and you're
doing what's true and you're making
choices that are going to be good and
and be good for your life and make you
happy and as long as you're not hurting
anyone else in that process that's okay
are you singing still are you still
writing music
bits and bobs i mean i've been busy i've
been busy i've been busy write a song
for walker the prequel i guess you
couldn't because
i mean you could
do they use modern music do they use
kind of sort of modern music with the
show or do they
is it there's a little bit of both
there's a little bit of both actually
the music on the show is
amazing between the score and the music
choices that they've made i mean it's cw
they always make great music choices
it's such a huge part of what they do
but um but larry our director again was
so
meticulous about music and i think it's
just it's just great
i'm i'm glad you know with what i've
what i've seen and what i've heard
it's it really
adds so much to the show you even see in
the trailer
um but yeah i've been doing little bits
and i mean even that was something we
loved so much about the podcast um is
that our our friend alex kinsey who's an
incredible musician and an incredible uh
singer-songwriter he wrote our theme
song and i got to sing on it and it's i
mean it's you know
it's a podcast theme song it's 20
seconds but being back in the studio for
13 minutes recording it was great that's
awesome
yeah it was it sucks because if you were
here i'd say come sing on my album
because we just recorded 14 new tracks
and i'm like i really love the songs and
you know i'd love for you to do some
harmonies but you're not available
you're not around i mean how could you
do it you don't have time you're not in
la
next time next time if i have more of a
heads up let me know next down next
album
all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with cat mcnamara
um who calls you cat who calls you
catherine
ooh it depends there's
it's funny because
when i grew up in missouri um
everyone called me catherine i was
always katherine then i moved to new
york and i was doing a show with
catherine zeta-jones and there were two
other catherines
in the show as well
and one of the actors pulled me aside my
first day and goes there's too many
catharines here you're gonna be katie
mack
so in new york
really everyone calls me katie or katie
mac yeah
and then i moved to la and i was working
with someone and they went
i don't really like katie i'm gonna call
you cat and so then in la i've always
been cat
but it's it's it's wild because now
there's certain people in my life that
call me catherine only and my family
calls me everything under the sun
and and so i sort of just let people
choose and it's
it's fun all right kids you think it'd
be fun
yeah you can call me i like katie mac
nobody calls me back all right katie mac
we'll go with claudine with [ __ ] talking
with cat mcnamara these are questions
that my top tier patrons get to ask if
you want to join patreon support the
podcast patreon.com inside of you i'll
write you a message afterwards claudine
you you kind of answer this question
claudia and says how was it returning to
the arrowverse and playing mia green
arrow again
it was great and and actually i can i
can speak a little more to that in that
um
you know eric and and all of the writers
on flash picked up right where we left
off i mean a year later as it were but
right where we would have left off and
it
it felt as though i was reading an arrow
script it felt like mia it sounded like
mia and mia has such a very particular
balance of brooding
um anger and sarcasm and it's a very
hard balance to strike sometimes and not
let it go too far either way and in
reading the script it was it was it just
felt right and i was so happy to just be
home
i love it lisa h what was it like
portraying the character of julie lowry
in the remake of the stand
such an iconic miniseries and novel and
did you see the original ministers prior
to being cast if so how did you think
they compared
yeah i i love the original mini series i
mean i'm a huge stephen king fan mick
garris came who's the director of the
original miniseries worked on
shadowhunters back in the day so i i
knew it quite well and um
playing julie she's quite a polarizing
character
and i was i was pretty nervous stepping
into those shoes because i i was hopeful
to
maintain that separation between self
and
the character um don't be a julie that's
all i keep saying to people but just the
fact that she is this personification of
narcissism and hedonism and gets to have
fun
in a world where so many people are
being so earnest and really fighting for
humanity julie's just living her best
life covered in fur and jewels and
sequins and drinking champagne and doing
whatever else she's doing
um and i also you know to be surrounded
with such incredible actors like nat
wolfe was my partner in crime for the
majority of it henry zaga i got to do
some great stuff alex skarsgard was in
the majority of you know the scenes that
i was in it was amazing to get to play
with those folks did you meet stephen
king
i didn't i'm so gutted oh god i'd love
to meet stephen king somebody got me his
autograph once at a book signing but
that's it he signed that cemetery i
believe for me
i have it up there i think
oh that's awesome where is it
no one cares michael
uh nico what's the most common question
you get when it comes to your character
on shadowhunters
oh um
i think
i think the most common question i get
is
uh what
what quality
are you do you find most similar to to
yourself and clary
and um
you know my answer to that is always
that that there's this loyalty
that clary has to the people that she
loves and this
clary always had this beautiful
willingness to find
hope in every situation and and it
wasn't the end unless there was always a
way to figure it out there was always a
solution there was always some glimmer
and some ember of hope existing in who
she was and i i find myself having that
same quality i could see that i could
see it
bob k what classic film would you remake
in starring
oh that's tough
um
i don't know i don't know if it would
ever need remaking but one of my
favorite classic films of all time is
gilda with rita hayworth from 1946 i
believe
it's like the end of noir and i just
love rita hayworth so much and maybe not
remaking that film but to do a film of
that era and to bring noir back
i could see you doing it
leanne what is something people would be
surprised to learn about you
shh
um
surprised to learn about me
that you have a that you can just
you could just
snap
you just go off on someone no oh no
no i'm directionally challenged is that
is that surprising uh so in other words
when somebody's to make a laugh you'll
go right
i just get i have no sense of direction
yeah i'm not great with it i'm not great
with it i know left and right and stuff
like that but i'm not great i'm not
great
yeah i'm i'm generally 180 degrees off
consistently
if i if i have a feeling that it's left
it'll almost always be so if i asked you
where a certain country was or so you're
probably not good with that stuff
i i would i'm geography i'm iffy with
but but you know if you ask me how to
get somewhere even if i've been there
before i'll probably get lost but you
know how i look at it i always find the
silver lining you know this
i have a lot of adventures along the way
good for you
that's a perfect way to think i like it
lena anne if you weren't an actress what
could you picture yourself doing for a
living
so if
if i could still be in the entertainment
industry i would probably direct
um i've been shadowing and learning and
and
dipping my toe in the water for the last
couple of years and and it's something
that i very much would like to do um i
also started writing during the pandemic
which
i've written you know non-fiction things
over the years but
but writing and telling stories and
doing things in that way it's new but i
love it
um
but if not i would probably go back to
economics i i before i was an actor i
wanted to go into developmental
economics did you yeah
didn't you try to do weren't you going
to get your master's degree from john
hopkins
yeah yeah i took i took a bit of a
sabbatical from that um
you know during
work right right i i do want to finish
that up you do you really want to finish
that
i do
look at you i mean you graduated high
school you graduated high school and you
were what 14
yeah you were homeschooled and then you
graduated with a college i mean with a
degree but by the time you were 17.
that about wraps it up for today
i love school i love learning
you know i just any any time i can
learn or glean something from uh
an experience or a person or a book or
anything i i try and do it what life's
all about what's your instagram
at
cat.mcnamara
and twitter
cat underscore mcnamara you know i
always tell this but my uh instagram is
the michael rosenbaum but my twitter my
name was too long so it's at michael
rosenbaum
they couldn't fix them they couldn't fit
an f and a in there so it's rose and
gone why not
throw a pun in there it's got character
yeah yeah
katie mac this has been great i love
it's been a long time coming i'm glad i
got to talk to you finally you look
fantastic your attitude makes me want to
have a better attitude
it does
you just have a great attitude towards
everything in life and it's just like i
i you know you we should all wake up and
and you know
act like you do and and do the things
that you do to get motivated and have
the gratitude and all these things i
feel like you're very grateful and
you're
very hard-working and you deserve
everything you get
well thank you i mean and you're right
that's what it comes down to for me it's
i'm i'm grateful i i feel very fortunate
and and
very humbled by you know the
the
opportunities that um
life has put in front of me you know
whether it's the people i get to work
with and the stories i get to tell and
the people i get to meet along the way
um
and it's
i if i can wake up every day and
remember that gratitude
and be excited to do whatever it is that
i have to
tackle that day
makes it all the better
what's the uh walker prequel called
the walker prequel is called walker
independence
walker independent so probably air
you're hoping in the fall so you guys
tune into that it'll be on the cw
any further questions i would direct to
jared padalecki no i don't know i don't
want to throw him into the bus yeah you
could throw him under the bus i'll call
him no i mean he's my grandson he's got
to help a grandma out you know he's got
to help his great-great-great-great
grandma out
okay mac i appreciate you what were you
gonna say
i said oh he makes a great great great
great grandma proud yeah good good good
good uh thanks for doing this thanks for
taking the time i know you're busy i
love you i wish the best for you
all the best to you
bye see ya
she's just very likable yeah and also
just busy
i've never met anyone that's what i was
saying
she's on her [ __ ] i mean talk about
someone who doesn't get anxiety really i
mean we talked about things but um
she's she's a rare breed yeah she
just goes
and works so hard
and uh it pays off um people like her
they like her i like her did you like
her i like her too yeah good
that's good i want to thank everybody
again for listening to the podcast and
sticking with us i know you're here for
kate catherine mcnamara
keep sticking around uh we appreciate it
watch on youtube there's also youtube
clips uh you can listen anywhere you get
your podcasts and
write a review it tremendously helps the
podcast when you write a review
and join patreon
patreon.com inside of you also thank you
for listening to talkville our new
podcast that ryan's a part of and uh we
just keep getting through these episodes
and um it's a lot of fun we watch every
smallville episode and then we talk
about it and critique it and sometimes
we have guests we just had kristin kruk
uh which was lovely
and um we'll say critique and celebrate
we critique celebrate i [ __ ] on it
occasionally sure but i don't really
[ __ ] on it a fan said i [ __ ] on it but i
just give my honest opinion on things
i'm a harshest critic
but uh
check out talkville
t-a-l-k-v-i-l-l-e you can watch on
youtube subscribe and anywhere you get
your podcast follow us at talkville pod
and talkville podcast on twitter
instagram and facebook uh thank you for
listening and uh right now we're gonna
get into the top tier patreons these are
the patrons that uh
give a lot to the podcast to keep it
going they really support it and i could
not
do it without them so without further
ado
here we go you ready for this ryan
i'm ready you hydrated
i'm hydrated now man great
all right here we go
nancy d
nancy d
leah s sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h by the way yukiko i saw that you
came on the zoom and then you left
last week we had a big patron zoom top
tier patron zoom and i saw yukiko's name
and then she vanished
so i was sad to see you go
jill e brian h brian was there nico p
brya robert b jason w sophie m kristen k
raj c joshua d cj p jennifer n stacy l
jamal f
janelle b kimberly e
mike e eldon soprano 99 more romero
santiago m chad w leanne p janine r maya
p matty s belinda n chris h dave h
sheila g brad d ray h tabitha t
tom n liliana a talia m betsy d chat l
marion meg k
big stevie w angel and
that's correct
angel mounds you won't forget rhiannon
c correct corey okay dev next and
michelle
uh d
hey hey we're not there yet jeremy
vegan v nope jeremy c there's two
michelle's two jeremy's [ __ ] andy
dwyer
t
gav
nader david
c all right john
c reilly john b reilly
brandy
uh
tough one
d brandy d your vor camille
m
yes yes the c
those they're the c but the
the new one the the what
the remember you asked if there were two
of them
the ch
ch the chief the chief
joey and am i right
did the c become the chief i don't know
but it's the chief
joey m design otg eugene and leah nicki
r just nikki glazer think nikki glazer
oh nikki g corey katie
nope b heather
l correct
jake
s no remember i said jake he's got a
father who's crazy jake
b jake busey oh right megan
remember you said something
making t t correct mel
s correct orlando
c correct
caroline
r correct
christine
yes correct sarah
nope remember sarah smile oh s or sarah
sanderson oh sorry eric
h
yes
jennifer
n no remember these are three in a row
jennifer r and then shane r and then
emma r correct jeremy
v correct andrew
m
correct robert
s g
zatoichi i don't know 77. andreas
s n n oracle chris
r yes correct michael
remember i said his name the actor
michael oh f correct
karina n samantha don't know
w
michelle
d correct amanda
r correct lovecraft
e love crafty love crafty all right
uh amanda
s correct and jen
gen b i'm i'm impressed i'm impressed
you nailed a lot of them this is this is
the end of it because you always nail
the first half as everybody knows but
now you're starting to squeeze in some
of the second half mnemonic devices yeah
i don't know i don't know but we're
doing it we're doing it um
guys i thank you for listening to the
podcast as i say over and over again
hopefully you don't get tired of it uh
keep listening
keep supporting join patreon if you want
and uh
from michael rosenbaum here in the
hollywood hills of california
i'm ryan days
a little wave for the wide camera uh
thanks jason our editor thanks bryce our
producer thanks cumulus
for uh you know working hard in this
pocket thank you ryan couldn't do it
without my main man thick and thin right
here here he is ryan taylor
show him some love and uh we will see
you next week be good yourselves
[Music]